[Musique]
j'ai un problème de maths house naître
d'ici à 2050
la terre sera peuplée de dix milliards
d'êtres humains aujourd'hui nous sommes
7 milliards
parmi ces 7 milliards 1 milliards
souffrent de malnutrition
donc selon vous de combien faut-il
augmenter la production agricole
mondiale pour nourrir ses 10 milliards
est-ce que vous avez une idée j'ai
oublié de donner une autre donnée à
l'heure actuelle on gaspille on gaspille
à peu près un tiers de la nourriture
mondiale
ça représente 1,3 milliard de tonnes de
nourriture qui ne sont jamais mangé avec
ce chiffre là est ce que ça change notre
première idée et il vous manque encore
un point aujourd'hui on estime qu'on
produit le double de la nourriture
nécessaire pour sept milliards d'êtres
humains donc avec tous ces chiffres
est ce que vous arrivez à une conclusion
parce que les experts aujourd'hui en
tout cas nos politiques arrivés à la
conclusion qu'on doit augmenter la
production agricole mondiale de 70%
et ça c'est sans tenir compte en fait
qu'il ya un tiers qui est gaspillée et
qui ont produit le double de ce qui est
nécessaire je pense que vous avez tous
entendu parler récemment du giec
vous voyez les scientifiques très très
très intelligente à qui on a demandé de
donner des préconisations pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
celui qui responsable de la montée des
eaux de la disparition des ours polaires
etc
eh ben c'est scientifique ils disent que
d'ici à 2050
il faut diminuer les gaz à effet de
serre de 50% alors les solutions
paraissent pas très évidente mais moi je
vous donner quelques chiffres qui
doivent vous inspirer des pistes à
l'heure actuelle la production agricole
est responsable de 14,6 pour cent des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et on
vient de dire que parmi cette production
école un tiers étaient gaspillés
donc il ya 5 % qui sert vraiment à rien
de gaz à effet de serre ensuite si on
prend juste la consommation de viande la
production la distribution le fait d'en
manger et en croisant les transports
l'accaparement des terres
et l'énergie consommée
la production de viande la consommation
de viande pardon est responsable de 15 %
des gaz à effet de serre c'est énorme
moi face à ce constat j'ai eu envie
d'agir parce que les solutions
je les ai vus et avec mon associé on a
eu envie de sauver le monde à coups de
fourchette alors qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on a ouvert un restaurant zéro déchet et
carbone neutre à bruxelles qui s'appelle
le local là vous demander qu'est ce que
c'est un restaurant zéro déchet est ce
qu'on mange
le reste des assiettes de nom de son
voisin dont vous n'avez pas manger le
reste de l'assiette de vos voisins
un récent en déchets c'est zéro déchet
c'est bien plus que ça notre engagement
pour la planète
il commence en amont on travaille en
direct avec des petits producteurs
locaux en belgique pour que dans votre
assiette
vous avez des produits locaux de saison
issus d'une agriculture biologique ou
raisonnée de ce fait 80% de nos achats
viennent de belgique
les 20% restants c'est une réalité
commerciale dont on ne sait pas se
couper ses du café et du cacao du vin
des agrumes mais on a un engagement chez
nous vous ne trouverez jamais d'avocats
l'avocat c'est vraiment un produit
controversé parce que ça crée un
déséquilibre écologique en consommant
beaucoup trop d'eau pour être produit
s'est souvent produit hors saison s'est
exporté deux pays très lointain avec une
empreinte carbone et surtout c'est un
désastre social pour les pays
producteurs car on confisque les
populations locales de ce produit qui
est la base de leur alimentation
alors le café pourrait être exactement
le même problème mais on peut pas
changer toutes les habitudes d'un cours
et croyez moi j'aurais bien vous
convertir à la chicorée avec ses
producteurs
on travaille en circuit court ça veut
dire qu'ils vivent le restaurant au
début c'était très compliqué parce que
eux-mêmes le disais c'est une perte de
temps c'est beaucoup de camions qui
rentrent dans bruxelles donc on a
réfléchi à comment agir et on a regroupé
nos producteurs par zones géographiques
comme ça c'est un camion par semaine qui
nous livre est donc moins d'empreinte
carbone de pots d'échappement dans
bruxelles également une un gain de temps
pour eux dans le champ ou en famille
ensuite avec ses producteurs
on travaille zéro déchet on privilégie
les contenants réutilisables et les
consignes ça veut dire que les livres
les
légumes ou les fruits sont livrés dans
des cagettes réutilisables chaque
semaine le lait dans des bouteilles de
verre et l'impact est réel si on prend
sur un an
notre partenariat avec le fermier qui
nous produit le lait la crème le fromage
les oeufs en un an
on a réussi à économiser 70 kg de
plastique et si on rapporte ça au nombre
de clients par jour on a à peu près 30
de places assises par an ça fait 2 kg de
plastique par personne et ça c'est sans
compter les 700 boîtes duff qu'on n'a
pas utilisée
là vous vous dites mais enfin le
plastique c'est recyclable
donc finalement pourquoi faire du zéro
déchet je vous dire quelque chose de
choquant préparez vous recycler c'est
pas bien ouais c'est toujours ça la
première fois les pays que nous sommes
développés on ne recycle pas ou très peu
qu'est ce qu'on fait on collecte vous
triez on trie et on revend ses déchets
aux pays en voie de développement
on ne recycle pas et puis alors on les
revend aux pays en voie de développement
il faut pas imaginer que le ballots de
plastique il est livré par un triporteur
en chine
à l'autre bout du monde donc ça veut
dire qu'on va envoyer recycler chez les
pauvres et qu'en plus on va émettre du
carbone parce qu'on va le faire via les
transports
donc il ya un vrai impact il y a un vrai
impact à avoir à ce niveau là en plus le
plastique
en fait ça se recyclent pas
éternellement une fois ça va deux fois
mais trois fois ce n'est plus possible
donc il faut savoir que vos bouteilles
en plastique d'eau elles finiront par
être incinérés donc pas reproduire des
gaz à effet de serre et même si on les
envoie dans les pays en voie de
développement souvent ils n'ont pas
forcément la capacité de les recycler et
ça finit sur une décharge à ciel ouvert
qui est elle-même et maîtrise de 5 % des
gaz à effet de serre à l'essai à
l'échelle mondiale juste par
fermentation en fait de ces plastiques
il y a aussi également les déchets
organiques sur ces déchets recyclés
triés par nous pays développés on estime
la masa à peu près 500 millions de
tonnes de déchets parmi ses 500 millions
50 % sont d'origine organique
qu'est-ce que l'organique c'est tout
bêtement les fleurs les restes de vos
repas or ces choses là en fait
peuvent se décomposer naturellement dans
l'environnement est aujourd'hui comme
elle se retrouve dans vos poubelles
elles vont aller dans une usine
d'incinération et là vous avez tous déjà
regardé en votre poubelle si vous jetez
votre aise de soupe ou votre aise de
carbonade flamande pour rester en
belgique
vous n'avez pas pouvoir le faire brûler
comme ça vous allez avoir besoin de deux
feux et puis de d'énergies fossiles pour
faire le brûler donc c'est complètement
aberrant on envoie des matières
organiques pour les brûlés alors
qu'elles peuvent être traitées autrement
donc il y a un impact il y a un impact
si on fait du compost si on trie ses
déchets organiques en amont parce qu'on
va le compost va permettre de créer une
sorte de terreau du must qui une fois
qui est répandu sur les sols va
permettre de capter les gaz à effet de
serre le carbone par la photosynthèse
végétales et de produire aussi du
méthane qui peut être réinjectés dans
les systèmes d'énergie des villes au
local dans notre récent zéro déchet on
trie nos déchets organiques
et encore heureusement parce que ça
représente quasiment 90% de nos déchets
les déchets cru tout ce qui est plus
cher et c'est reparti chez nos
producteurs fertiliser les sols et
déchets cuit et les restes d'assiette
repartent dans un projet de compost dans
bruxelles qui s'appelle cycle organique
équivalent est valorisée comme je
voulais divia du terreau et de la
méthanisation
tous ces actions permettent de réduire
nos poubelles
mais être zéro déchet ce n'est pas
seulement réduire ses poubelles ou faire
du compost c'est aussi gaspillé mois en
travaillant mieux parce que le meilleur
déchet c'est celui qui n'existe pas
la chef du restaurant mon associé
cuisine zéro déchet elle tend à utiliser
100 % des matières organiques qu'on
reçoit alors ça pousse à être un vent à
être créatifs à travailler à réfléchir
je vais vous donner quelques tips pour
briller hors pack vous êtes vos parents
ce soir les épluchures de légumes ça se
mange le pain rassis ça se cuisine et
les carcasses de poulets sa sauvegarde
si vous prenez un légume qu'il est issue
d'une agriculture biologique vous avez
juste à bien la levée pour enlever la
terre mais vous pouvez le manger tel
quel et si ça vous rebute de manger des
épluchures de légumes et bien vous
pouvez les valoriser dans un bouillon et
ça évite d'acheter des choses toutes
prêtes au supermarché qu'ils sont
bourrés d'additifs et qu'on sûrement
jamais vu l'ombre d'un légume le par à 6
à ce concert mais super longtemps on
peut le réduire en miettes faire de la
chapelure et si vous aimez cuisiner fait
des gâteaux avec ça remplace la farine
et c'est beaucoup plus anxieux et en
belgique on fait même de la bière avec
le pain rassis on n'a pas réinventer
l'eau chaude en cuisine avec ont associé
on a juste réfléchi réfléchit à
valoriser à arrêter le gaspillage et
finalement faire ce que faisaient nos
grands mères puisque avant nous chaque
matière compte et il fallait faire
attention si vous venez chez nous au
restaurant vous verrez que vous mangez
tout dans le poireau on va vous faire le
vert dans une soupe leblanc comme vous
le manger chez vos parents et leur a dit
celle les cheveux vous en avez jamais
mangé j'imagine mais en fait ça se mange
et ses superbes on pouvait faire des
beignets avec ou des pick-ups toutes ces
actions vont avoir un impact direct sur
nos poubelles
si vous passez un soir de collecte à
bruxelles devant le restaurant vous
verrez quasiment pas de poubelle ou une
poubelle par par semaine devant les
autres restaurants arrêtez-vous la
prochaine fois c'est vraiment une
montagne mais réduire la taille de nos
poubelles
c'était pas assez on avait aussi envie
de réduire notre empreinte écologique
si je reprends l'exemple du pain rassis
il y à un chiffre qu'il faut retenir
quand vous jetez une baguette de pain à
la poubelle parce que vous allez pas la
manger
c'est comme si vous gaspillez une
baignoire d'eau c'est énorme
donc derrière le gaspillage alimentaire
il ya aussi un problème de consommation
de ressources naturelles et on sait
aujourd'hui qu'elles sont limitées
du coup nous on s'est dit qu'on voulait
notre restaurant éco-conçus qui consomme
moins d'énergie
alors on a pensé une cuisine de
restaurant où vous avez un four basse
consommation d'énergie
une plonge donc un lave-vaisselle
professionnelle qui va utiliser la
vapeur de la planche précédente pour
laver la suivante moins d'eau et alors
on a un petit bijou aussi on a un frigo
éco-conçus il permet d'allonger la durée
de vie des vitamines et des minéraux des
fruits et légumes dans un restaurant les
fruits et les légumes vous les mettez
dans une chambre froide
c'est comme un gros frigo comme vous
avez chez vous mais très très froid et
le problème c'est que ça coupe le
développement des légumes vous n'avez
plus les vitamines et les minéraux et
les vitamines et les minéraux c'est gage
de fraîcheur
donc quand un restaurant mais livraison
fraîche etc
là forcément été livré le jour même
autrement après 24 heures dans une
chambre froide
il n'y a pas d'intérêt nous ce frigo
pulvérise des nanoparticules et permet
d'allonger la durée de vie des fruits
légumes
résultat on a une chambre froide qui est
la moitié de celle d'un restaurant
classique
donc on ne conduise de l'électricité et
le fonctionnement de ce frigo et à base
d'un moteur à ultrasons et ça consomme
beaucoup moins d'énergie
l'eau qui est pulvérisée et l'équivalent
d'une demi chasse d'eau l'éco conception
c'est aussi dans le design d'un
restaurant est ce que vous connaissez la
différence entre la déconstruction et la
démolition
je vais prendre un exemple qui va vous
parler quand vous faites un château de
lego si vous le démolissent et pour en
construire un autre c'est la
déconstruction
par contre si par le plus grand des
hasards vous le tabasser à coups de
marteau et vous y mettez le feu
ce que j'espère pas tout est perdu il ya
plus rien à faire et aujourd'hui c'est
un des grands mâles du site du secteur
du bâtiment démolir coûte moins cher et
beaucoup plus rapide mais ça crée une
somme de déchets pharaonique qu'on ne
sait pas traiter et qui est bien plus
supérieur aux déchets ménagers que vous
pouvez produire en tant que citoyen or
si je déconstruis je passais plus de
temps mais je vais favoriser le réemploi
et à bruxelles
il ya vraiment un courant qui s'est
produit autour de cette déconstruction
vous pouvez le voir il ya des travaux
partout y compris ici à côté et donc si
on valorise ces déchets qui n'en n'ont
ce sens pas on crée une nouvelle sorte
de richesses alors nous on a demandé à
nos artisans à nos architectes à notre
designer de nous construire une salle de
restaurant en matériaux de
déconstruction est alors attention vous
allez pas arrivée dans un restaurant
fait en palettes de bois ce que tout le
monde s'attend à voir parce que là aussi
autres faits choquants les palettes de
bois c'est pas durable en fait ce sont
des objets qui sont consignés et qui
sont faits pour avoir un cycle de vie
circulaire toujours être réemployés et
la plupart du temps surtout c'est pas
être de bois ne sont pas issus d'une
forêt labellisés c'est à dire avec un
vrai traitement de la déforestation et
caetera et de replantation nous si vous
venez au restaurant et bien vous allez
voir l'étape de la commission européenne
des tables de bureaux grise moche qui
ont été recouvertes de lino recouper en
table de restaurant et qui sont super
joli on a les chaises en plastique
recyclé ou alors on a encore l'éclairage
comme vous voyez ici qui est fait à
partir d'éclairage récupérés sur des
chantiers de démolition et remis à neuf
et à la lecture des prix qu'on a pu
recevoir à ce sujet vous est bluffé vous
savez pas que c'est la déconstruction
la dernière chose qu'on a récemment
installé au restaurant après un an
c'est une enseigne éco conçu chez nous
pas d'anciennes lumineuse que vous allez
voir un kilomètre chez nous vous avez
une ancienne en acier entièrement
recyclable ou le logo est peint avec un
vernis naturel pour réfléchir la lumière
des phares ou la lumière de la lune
résultat le jour on s'en va on enlève
cette enseigne et vous pouvez la fonte
pour faire autre chose c'était vraiment
important pour nous d'avoir cet
engagement jusqu'au bout de l'éco
conception du restaurant pour limiter le
gaspillage alimentaire comme on l'a vu
mettre en avant 1-0 déchets est aussi
limiter l'usagé des ressources
néanmoins on a voulu aller plus loin je
pense que vous êtes aussi conscient
aujourd'hui qu'il y a il y à un une
situation de crise sur les gaz à effet
de serre et qu'il faut s'engager aussi
pour qu'on se émettre moins de gaz à
effet de serre vous êtes sans doute peut
être descendu déjà dans la rue
manifester on est à bruxelles le berceau
et nous on a eu envie de bain d'aller
plus loin dans sur cette empreinte
carbone et on s'est fait labellisés par
co2 logic qui nous a permis de mettre en
place un travail pour réduire cette
empreinte carbone dans le restaurant je
vous donnais un autre chiffre
j'aime beaucoup les chiffres aujourd'hui
un repas classique moyen en belgique
ces 2,5 kg de carbone si vous enlevez la
viande de ce repas ou le chocolat
donc si vous prenez plutôt un repas
végétarien et un dessert de saison avec
des pommes des poires comme on est en
hiver vous allez passer en dessous de la
barre des 1 kg de carbone par par repas
c'est juste hallucinant vous avez un
vrai impact à avoir via votre
alimentation sur le réchauffement
climatique alors au restaurant nous on a
décidé de diminuer la portion de taille
la portion de viande qu'on vous sert on
a également décidé de mettre plus en
avant des viandes qui ont une
consommation de carbone moindres tels
que le poulet qui est vraiment l'animal
pour ça qu'il va tout manger et qui en
plus n'est pas comme le boeuf qui est
vraiment énormément producteurs de
carbone de fait des terres accaparées de
la nourriture nécessaire est également
aussi des pets de vaches qui sont
vraiment un problème pour la
méthanisation de l'atmosphère
ce n'est pas une blague ensuite le jeudi
chez nous c'est toujours vj le plat du
jour est toujours végétariens et ça
c'est pour montrer aux gens que le
végétarien ben c'est pas un gros mot
c'est super bon et en fait une vraie
alternative végétarienne c'est pas un
steak frites sans le steak c'est
vraiment construit sa du goût et c'est
bien mieux que la viande
il ya une part de notre empreinte
carbone qu'on ne sait pas réduire si
vous venez au restaurant ce soir avec
vos parents vous allez prendre la
voiture et ça ne peut pas influer là
dessus on est en train d'installer un
parking à vélos mais ça suffit pas alors
pour cette part qu'on ne sait pas
réduire on a décidé de financer des
projets en afrique pour lutter contre la
déforestation
on a décidé de prendre nos
responsabilités parce qu'il ya une
responsabilité en tant que pays envoie
en tant que pays développés d'aider les
pays en voie de développement
ça fait sans encombre pollue nous ça
fait longtemps qu'on pollue qu'on impose
une croissance effrénée une consommation
des ressources naturelles sans limites
et qu' on impose à tout le monde via un
système de mondialisation aujourd'hui on
se rende compte que ça a un effet
pervers sur la planète que les choses
sont en danger qu'on est en état de
crise on va demander à des pays pauvres
de fournir le même effort que nous sans
les aider
alors nous on avait envie de prendre nos
responsabilités pour revenir au thème
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya une limite
lorsqu'on a lancé le projet de
restaurant zéro déchet et carbone neutre
à bruxelles
on n'a pas vraiment eu un accueil ultra
enthousiaste or c'est génial ça va trop
marché nous a plutôt un peu questionné
souvent on nous prend encore pour des
utopistes écologique et si on n'était
pas à bruxelles on ne nous imagine raid
en larzac avec une peau de mouton sur
les épaules
comme vous voyez je pense que je suis
assez normal et donc ça a été quand même
un combat
aujourd'hui ce qu'on se rencontre après
un an c'est qu'on n'est pas un
restaurant à la mode on n'est pas un
concept on a ouvert une voie
il ya un mouvement il ya une lame de
fond qui est en train de se créer à
bruxelles la preuve en est la ville de
bruxelles à la c1 a lancé un appel à
projets pour le zéro déchet dans la
restauration
les choses changent nous face à la
situation de crise
aujourd'hui par rapport au réchauffement
climatique on a eu envie d'agir
et si on s'était limité à écouter l'avis
des autres on n'aurait rien fait et on a
une petite voix dans notre tête qui nous
a dit on peut agir et on s'est dit si on
agit
on va sûrement en inspirer d'autres et
on va faire ce qu'on appelle la part du
colibri les ressources naturelles sont
limitées mais notre action à nous elle
doit être illimité pour les préserver
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]